We have been meeting for 40 hours.
40 hours in two sessions
only interrupted by a shortened Sunday.
Then we had an agreement
on a common European cereal price.
With this the European cause
has taken a big step ahead.
It is such a huge step
that I would argue -
- that the united European ecomony
is now even more irrevocable.
It is now a few hours later
and I am still pleased -
- with everyone in the Council,
in the neighboring rooms, -
- but also the critical observers,
the journalists.
The negotiations were very difficult,
because everyone wanted the best for Europe, -
- but at the same time had to get
the best result for their own country.